the knowledge or knowing which is at the
start or immediately our object cannot
be anything else but immediate knowledge
itself a knowledge of the immediate or
what simply is our approach to the
object must also be immediate or
receptive
we must alter nothing in the object as
it presents itself in apprehending it we
must refrain from trying to comprehend
we now begin the main body of the
phenomenology of spirit looking at this
section called sense certainty and why
are we beginning there well like I put
here shouldn't we begin at the beginning
this is the question that Hegel is
posing for us if we have gone through
all of this sort of conceptual
preparation in the preface and the
introduction and we arrived at the point
where we've realized that we need to be
doing phenomenology we need to allow
things to present themselves to us
things that have already occurred but
which matter to us as as subjects that
can relive them we need to have a kind
of hands-off passive attitude and what
kind of objects make the most sense for
doing this why not begin with what seems
to be most basic the objects of sense
the things that we perceive and this is
where indeed much phenomenology begins
with thinking about a red ball or a
green ball all of us roll but as Hegel
is going to reveal to us we're not
really beginning at the beginning
because we never actually have a
beginning to start from it always turns
out that this immediacy that we think
that we have conceals the fact that
there's mediation going on and we will
get to an end where everything has been
connected together and all the
mediations have been unveiled but we
have to actually start from somewhere so
instead of saying beginning if you want
to quibble about this we can call it a
starting point we commence the process
and the representation that we make to
ourselves of what we're doing at the
beginning is that consciousness has to
be purely receptive it takes in the
object as Hegel says the knowledge that
that we're getting with is immediate
knowledge that is knowledge that doesn't
have anything standing in the way and
you might even say in a certain respect
I'm already confusing things by showing
this arrow here what we really want to
have is the object just
right smack up against consciousness
presenting itself to it and through the
you know the now be careful the medium
of the senses but think about what it's
like when we're in the moment when we're
just paying attention to what's going on
when we feel that we are being just
purely receptive there's no distance
there's no filter between us and the
world that we're experiencing that is
something that's quite attractive
so Hegel says this is what we are going
to begin with it's going to turn out
that that's not a good day you know it's
not measuring up to its own pretensions
the object presents itself to us as
immediate nothing between us and int
nothing intervening nothing filtering
nothing conditioning it as what simply
is being this is our raw immediate
in-your-face encounter with beings as
such that's what's being presented here
and consciousness then has some jobs to
do not only does it have to be purely
receptive it has to take care not to
alter anything not to bring too much of
itself to the experience to let the
experience and pin japon up upon it not
to allow the experience to be
conditioned or put into a framework by
consciousness so as Hegel will say the
translation here is a little bit a
little bit tricky what we want to do is
not allow two comprehension to stand in
the place of apprehension we want to
distance those from each other
comprehension here the understanding in
that sense is big I think this
conceptual knowledge that we've been
talking about for so long and what we
want instead is a raw pure unadulterated
how Fossum just grabbing on to the thing
itself seizing hold
there's a little bit of you know
trickery here because because I even you
know to grab to grip fossum to grab on
to as well both ways we can we can make
sense of this but the idea is that we as
consciousness have a capacity for taking
in what is coming to us from the object
what is coming to us through our senses
the experience that we take
because of its kind of great account
since certainty immediately appears as
the richest kind of knowledge indeed an
knowledge of infinite wealth for which
no bounds can be found either when we
reach out into space and time in which
it is dispersed or when we take a bit of
this wealth and by division enter into
it
moreover sense certainty appears to be
the truest knowledge for it is not as
yet admitted to anything from the object
with the it has the object before it and
it's perfect entirety but in the event
this very certainty proves itself to be
the most abstract and porous truth all
that it says about what it knows is just
that it is and it's truth contains
nothing but the sheer being of the thing
consciousness for its part is is in this
certainty only a pure I or I am in it
only as a pure this and the object
similarly only has appear this eye this
particular eye and certain of this
particular thing not because I
consciousness in knowing it have
developed myself or thought about it in
various ways and also not because the
thing of which I am certain in virtue of
a host of distinct qualities would be in
its own self of which complex of
connections or related in various ways
to other things neither these has
anything to do with the truth of sense
certainty here neither I nor the thing
has the significance of the complex
process of mediation the ahright is not
here the significance of a manifold
imagining or thinking nor does the
things signify something that has a host
of qualities on the contrary the thing
is and it is merely because it is it is
this is the essential point for self for
sense knowledge and this pure being or
simple immediacy constitutes its truth
similarly certainly as a connection is
an immediate pure connection
consciousness is I nothing more appear
this the singular consciousness knows
appear this or the single item
it doesn't take long for Hegel to start
already engaging and some dialectical
transformations where you thought things
were this way and it turn out to be this
way and in Section 91 this is going to
occur really in two important ways so we
begin from this conception as he says of
sense certainty as being exactly what we
were looking for it's the richest kind
of knowledge and it's the truest kind of
knowledge let's look at how he makes
that case or rather doesn't make the
case but allows sense certainty itself
and the way it works to make the case
for it
so why is it the richest kind of
knowledge well
the consciousness is relating itself to
these objects and the objects are
impinging upon consciousness and it can
turn to any one of them that it wants to
he says that it's rich in that there's
almost an infinity of possibilities as
we range through space and time
think about your your sensible manifold
as you're looking around you know I'm
looking around in a room and there are
who knows how many thousand books in
this room each of which has its spine
some color and I can range my eyes over
any single one of them as I'm moving
from object to object to object or if I
look at a spot on the chalkboard space
and time will offer me this infinite
variety of spectacles to to engage it
and even better if I take any one given
object and I sort of unpack it and look
at it very closely I can see more and
more and more in it I can take a piece
of chalk like this that originally I
just see is a tiny cylinder and I
noticed that the bevels
on it are at different angles if I start
paying attention to what I'm doing they
do these these sort of things that
mindfulness exercises I'm not going to
do this but I mean you can take this
piece of chalk and stick it in your
mouth as well and start you know
experiencing it by taste I won't do that
I'd do that
and I found that I don't like chalk and
you can let it linger you know they do
this in mindfulness exercises quite
often with food with a raisin first
you're supposed to like touch it to your
lip and then you like put it on your
tongue and now you like let it linger
and then you bite into it and you get
the juicy you know sweetness of it well
okay that's what he's talking about is
an infinite variety and this is all
concrete so this is why it's so rich
concrete as opposed to the abstract as
opposed to the general you want to see
what you know chalk the hardness of
chalk feels like squeezed a little bit
in your hand or you know rub a bit on
your finger and feel the dryness of it
you know listen to the sound that it
makes that's all concrete that's all
coming to us through our senses so he
says because of its content this is is
the richest kind of knowledge a
knowledge of infinite wealth for which
no bounds can be found you know a space
and time we can move around as much as
we want in them time you can say alright
I'm gonna stop perceiving right now
ain't gonna happen I suppose of you you
know gouge your eyes up but even then
your brain is gonna be having some sort
of sensory impressions of blankness or
whatever it is that you see when you're
not seeing anything so he says we can
buy we can take a bit of this wealth and
by division enter into it that's what
we're talking about is like looking at
an object you don't look at your hand
notice the ink spots that I must have
like touched the the pennant of myself
and look at them various colors you know
is actually right when we look at
objects and we look at them carefully
they reveal all sorts of things to us
that we didn't originally think we're
there that we didn't really see that's
why when you're doing art it's so
important to be a good spectator to
really see what's there so I'm going to
draw on my hand
I need to look at where shadows actually
fall not just where I think they fall
but where they actually do fall on the
object that I'm perceiving
so it's a richest kind of knowledge
that's great
it's also the truest kind of knowledge
why because it's not intervening it's
not taking anything from consciousness
and imposing it on the object it's not
making objects line up with each other
and compare against each other it's not
bringing any filters any preconceptions
any structures table just letting the
experience happen letting the sensory
data flow over one so that you can just
see what's there so far it sounds so
pretty good but Hegel is going to say
well that's not actually what's going on
because it says in the any event the
very certainty Cruz itself to be the
most abstract and porous truth all that
it says about what it knows is just that
it is so what we're getting with these
objects it is not really an object per
se but just me just something that is
what does it mean for something to truly
be an object it means that it has all
this a whole bunch of qualities and
we're going to see why this matters in a
moment and it also means that it relates
itself to other objects that it finds
itself is a matrix with them that it
connects itself with them that it's not
just something totally independent and
on its own for consciousness to
experience that is for consciousness to
experience an object as an object he
says consciousness would perceive things
as a batch of qualities a rich complex
of connections related in various ways
other things
so this isn't happening in sense
certainty instead consciousness is just
being confronted with the raw being what
it is what lies in front of it what
impinges upon it and consciousness
reveals itself to us as being what Hegel
calls the pure eye because if it's just
going to be receptive like that it can't
bring anything of itself and at least
insofar as it is receptive for the
person who's doing the perceiving the
person who's conscious the only thing
that matters is this you know you might
say ability to mirror what is out there
this capacity to take in what's coming
in from the outside and make that you
what it is so I can't have any qualities
itself it can't have any determinacy
itself says consciousness is in this
certainty only a pure eye or I am in it
preserve it's really interesting only as
a pure this can't even really call it it
I cuz that's already to ascribe it some
sort of property some qualities isn't it
this that's all we got is this now
that's not very rich is it
that's pretty abstract and it's not even
giving us the truth of say consciousness
or the person or the subject or the
truth of the object or the truth of the
relationship between them just giving us
this relationship between one this and
another this it's not telling us an
awful lot anymore is it so here's where
the dialectical transformation has taken
place as we follow out what is actually
entailed in sense certainty in the
operation of experi
this way he says this this particular I
I am certain of this particular thing
not because I qua consciousness and
knowing I'd have developed myself they
thought about it various ways that can't
be going on if I want to stay in the
moment if I don't want to get away from
this pure certainty that sense is able
to give me as soon as I start thinking
about it I've lost him I'm no longer in
sin certainty I may have a relationship
to the object and it may be a richer
truer relationship but it's no longer
than one of sense certainty he says in
in knowing it I have developed myself
have thought about it in various ways
and also not because the thing of which
I'm certain would be in itself a rich
complex of connections
neither of these has anything to do with
the truth of sense certainty so Setzer
indeed turns out to be something that we
don't actually experience it might be
said to be rather imaginary because what
we do experience is my thinking about
things or your thinking about things as
a determinant being in determinate ways
over time with in space in terms of
something more than just this and this
this doesn't tell me anything does it so
he says on the contrary the thing is and
it is merely because it is it is this is
the essential point for sense knowledge
and this pure being or a simple
immediacy constitutes its truth so the
truth of sense certainty is not the fact
that sense certainty is actually giving
us an unmediated relation the truth of
sense certainty is rather than it's the
poorest form of knowledge that it's only
a beginning point that it can only yield
us this is in some sort of relation to
each other that has yet to be determined
in any significant concrete way it's not
really the cut most concrete form of
knowledge it's actually the most
abstract so he says
justice is I nothing more pure this the
singular consciousness knows a pure this
or the single item so you notice what
we're doing now we're actually sort of
closing in on consciousness as a this
being related now to another this and
the entire universe is kind of closing
in upon this upon these two this is all
that's really happening
but when we look carefully at this pure
being which constitutes the essence of
this certainty in which this certainty
pronounces to be its truth we see that
much more is involved an actual sense
certainty is not merely this pure
immediacy but an instance of it among
the countless differences cropping up
here we find in every case at the
crucial one is that and since certainty
pure being and once splits up into what
we have called the two this is one this
as I and the other this as object when
we reflect upon this difference we find
that neither one nor the other is only
immediately present and sense certainty
but each is at the same time mediated I
have his certainty through something
else that is the thing and it similarly
is in a sense certainty through
something else that is through the eye
Hegel is making three important points
engaging in three important transitions
or showing us three important
realizations one right after another in
this rather short passage section 92
there's a lot that's that's packed in
here and if we want to sort of trace it
an outline we're going from a discussion
of sense certainty to a contrast between
essence and example and then splitting
between two different this--is and then
we're look we're tackling the issue of
immediacy or mediation so let's look at
what's going on here since this is
actually a pretty crucial point for
what's happening with sense certainty
sense certainty presents itself as if
it's providing us with the pure being of
things the pure being in experience and
doing so in a way that's completely
immediate and Hegel talks now about the
relation between essence and example now
the word essence Bazin we can understand
it in the classic sense of essence as
sort of what is happening in in all
instances or particulars for examples
what it is that connects them all
together but also it's connected with
the notion of you know being itself and
here's where it gets really interesting
so when we're talking about sense
certainty and we're thinking about it it
has such does sense certainty really
have an essence think about that for a
moment try to imagine for yourself a
case where you are just completely there
in the moment a passive receptive
observer of everything that's going on
maybe your people watching you're just
taking in the people in the crowd and
you're not really thinking you're not
trying to figure out anything about them
you're just taking it all in or you're
at a concert and you're just listening
to the band and watching the spectacle
or you've managed to you know do some
in fulness training and they're sitting
down in a meal and instead of thinking
about the day or you know about what's
gonna what's the next course you're just
like totally there for the food and the
wine or the beer or whatever you're
drinking now if you capture the essence
of sense certainty know what you've done
with any of those examples is precisely
discuss an example any metaphor that we
can use whether it's of you know the
mind is mirror or Stillwater's or
anything like that
is not an essence but just an example of
what the passivity or the receptivity of
sense certainty would be like the
immediacy of it you know when you're in
that that zone okay we can use words
like zone and we can talk about that
experience but here's the thing
it's sense certainty sense certainty is
always going to be a matter of
determinate experiences except when
we're thinking about sentencing when
we're talking about it when we're making
it an object of our own thought that way
you can do this kind of abstraction
can't wait and talk about yeah man you
just need to be in the moment just need
to experience just don't put any of
yourself into it
just let the objects talk to you that's
all rather abstract so he says when we
look at this that's supposed to be in
essence what we really get is a bunch of
examples we see that more is involved an
actual sense certainty any example that
we want to think of is an example an
instance in this text right by schpeel
in German a particular thing that we can
wrap our our heads around or our senses
around so he says among the countless
differences cropping up we find in every
case of the crucial one is that in sense
certainty pure being is pure immediacy
splits up into two things the eye on one
side who's supposed to be experiencing
passively taking things in could get
pure eye and then the object another
this and you'd say well they're they're
really both the same because they're
both this's we don't even know that
about them we're not that far along in
our on our investigation but we have a
splitting that's taking place a
separation when somebody is supposed to
be there just in the moment experiencing
if it's them that's they're just
experiencing then it's not so you know
pure and immediate as we assumed that it
was and we can distinguish two different
polls to two different sides to it so he
says there's this as I and the other
this is object and then when we begin to
reflect on that difference so not not
just being in the situation but
reflecting on what's going on there we
see that it's not really immediate as we
thought it was known as I put immediacy
versus not media see but mediation an
actual mediation that's taking place
interestingly and this is sort of a
signing up to the immediacy can only be
immediacy in relation to five means of
the versus mediation which means that
there's actually AIDS deviation going on
between immediacy and mediation which
means that in an a galilean standpoint
immediacy anytime you see immediacy
coming up expect that that's not going
to last very long there always is going
to be some sort of mediation because you
don't get pure immediacy it's just not
there not when we analyze it not only
pay attention to what's really going on
so what do we find out well we go back
to the this I
and that this object and he says when we
reflect on this difference we find out
that neither one nor the other is only
immediately present in sense certainty
that's not what's really happening in
sense certainty incest certainty this
object is what it is because of the
mediation of the dis I like was the this
I is whatever it is able to take in and
of this object able to be receptive
because of another mediation going on
both of them are mediating each other
they're existing in what we call a
relation so it was actually mistaken to
think that we had some sort of pure
being that coupled the two of them
together and a face difference they
fused into each other somehow he says
neither one nor the others immediately
present each is at the same time
mediated I have this certainty I have
sent certainty through something else
I'm able to give this what seems to me
immediate experience because something
else is offering that to me if I'm
eating a piece of chocolate and I say
well this is an immediate experience I'm
just tasting chocolate now and tasting
all these different you know things
built into the thing you know maybe it's
milk chocolate dark chocolate or has a
little bit of orange or mint in it who
knows I'm doing so through the actual
thing that's what's providing me with
that experience I'm not just sort of
making it up inside my head I'm having
it through something else that's not me
but the experience is occurring in me in
my consciousness and the thing is only
able to be the thing that it is and to
give the possibility of you know those
impressions to impinge that certainty
because I'm letting it do so because I'm
perceiving it because I am involved so
he says
I have the certainty through something
else the thing it is in self certainty
only through the eye so now we need to
look a little bit more carefully at
what's really going on here
it is not just we who make this
distinction between essence and instance
between immediacy and mediation on the
contrary we find it within sense
certainty itself and it is not it is to
be taken up in the form in which it is
present there not as we have just
defined it one of the terms is positive
in sense certainty in the form of a
simple immediate being or is the essence
the object the other however is posited
as what is unintentional and mediated
something which instead certainty is not
in itself but through the mediation of
an other the eye a knowing which knows
the object only because the object is
well the knowing may either be or not be
but the object is it is what is true or
it is the essence it is regardless of
whether it is known or not and it
remains even if it is not known whereas
there is no knowledge if the object is
not there
in Section 93 Hegel might actually
appear to be going back on what he just
told us in Section 92 but what he's
doing is he's backing up a little bit
and saying let's go about this and let's
see where the the object of our
investigation leads us we know now that
we're gonna find all sorts of mediations
happening but let's see what sensing
sense certainty can reveal to us when we
analyze it so he says it's not just we
in section 82 who make this distinction
between essence an example or instance
immediacy and mediation we find it with
an incensed certainty itself so if we're
paying close attention to what actually
goes on within sense certainty what it's
what's requiring what it's involving
then we're going to see this same just
the same distinctions he says it's not
to be taken up in the foot that's to be
taken up in the form in which its
present they're not as we've just
defined so we're backing off from what
we did in 92 and now we're gonna see how
things are going on and send certainty
so that certainty posits as he says the
object or the the being has something
simple something immediate and and
something essential as what's really
going on there is what really matters
and it's breaking up the process or the
dynamic connection sense perception into
something else that then cast off and is
not really being essential as he says
not being immediate only existing for
something else not in itself but
existing because of another and the
other is the sense experience
so without he's saying without some sort
of sense experience going on
no I this is interesting because
normally we think about it well I have
sense experiences and you know I'm the
one who's really calling the shots
because I don't know like
turns around and looks at stuff and
that's my eyeballs or my tongue or my
skin that's taking that in if I wasn't
here there's nothing to perceive but
since certainty the way that it presents
itself to us at the beginning is saying
no there's all sorts of things in the
world and whether you're there to
perceive them or not that's not really
that important this is where the real
stuff is going on your does the one who
happens to be along for the
epistemological ride you're the one who
gets to take in the things but what
you're taking in is coming from what
actually it is what is true so he'll go
on and he'll say this term is is
positive as you know simple immediate
being as the essence so the eye is
related to the dot the object through
knowing that knowing is purely
contingent it doesn't have to happen for
the object to be the object for this to
already be in existence
he says the knowing knows the object
only because the object is it is what is
true it is the essence it is regardless
of whether it's known or not so if
knowing doesn't take place that's fine
as far as the object is concerned it
doesn't need the knower the eye the
person to be knowing the object if a
waterfall is there and it's flowing it's
flowing whether we actually go and
perceive it or not you know from this
point of view if the tree falls in the
forest does it make any noise yeah it
makes noise it just doesn't have anyone
there to perceive it there is the
possibility of perception whether
somebody is actually perceiving it or
not whether somebody is knowing it or
not so he says it remains even if it's
not known we're going to get the objects
not there there is no knowledge of the
object because there's nothing to know